[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast where we are investigating the
question what to do when your
semi-domesticated animals are facing the
wrong way
um it is actually the Q a segment of
what I am led to understand is the
156th
1556th live stream that we have done and
that is going to involve questions which
should if everything goes as planned
proceed answers that should be extremely
compelling yes so compelling Just Jump
Right In I keep forgetting to say in the
main episode that uh
Discord the Discord server votes on a
question they want us to answer every
week and we start there what are you
doing what the heck is going on here all
right
Batman I don't know
I was back biting is what that was that
was exactly back it's about to happen
again all right this doesn't really
happen no it is happening yeah
compelling when we say it doesn't happen
it just has happened yeah it's like the
error in that paper
which I was in the paper maybe it was
dyed suddenly where they said the
chances of something happened were
exactly zero yeah yeah
um yeah right the chances of something
that happened having happened is zero
yeah no yeah yeah
more words to get to where they were
headed yeah indeed well it worked buddy
yeah good yeah you scared off your
friend by back biting no I think he was
just being Fairfax okay
so we got actually two questions from
Discord this week because uh we didn't
have one last week
if memory serves first could Brett
could you yes okay
could Brett clarify whether he thinks
that the science truly shows that the
climate is in serious danger of
catastrophic global warming due to human
use of fossil fuels causing a rise in
CO2 it isn't really their limb of
science I don't blame for being cautious
not wanting to go out on that limb
you know this is a puzzle that I would
say is like the
the question of vaccine safety and
efficacy
in the following sense when you and I
first encountered the news of the
vaccines headed down the pike before
anybody in the public had gotten one
we were hopeful about the utility
and alarmed at what we were being told
about the safety and we were alarmed not
because we knew anything was on uh was
harmful about them but because we knew
that nobody who was in a position to
tell us that they were safe could
possibly know because who knows you know
they had only existed for months how
could anybody know that they don't have
a bad effect a year two years five years
down the road
so the question is well what do you do
in that position and the answer is you
grow up and you
address the fact that no they are not
safe they may be better
you know they may be more valuable than
they are risky but that's a discussion
that has to happen and it turned out
that they were neither safe nor
effective and in fact are harmful
in this case
the right answer to that question
I believe is we do know that we are in
danger
from
human activity elevating the tendency of
the atmosphere to capture
Heat
um
and the way we know that does not
involve these
fancy models which are no doubt wrong
and polluted by the politics of the
environment and nor am I saying that
this will happen nor am I saying that we
know that this is where we're headed but
what we do know
we know from uh the work of arenius
actually that CO2 captures Arrhenius
it's a person yeah
um
that we know that CO2 captures Heat
we know that there is we know that
methane
does too that's in fact much more potent
than CO2
we know that there's a tremendous amount
of Frozen methane in the Arctic
there is a plausible scenario in which
the level of warming that is induced by
the change in CO2 level that is clearly
the result of human activity causes a
burst of methane to be released from the
Arctic and that that causes enough extra
warming to release more methane from the
Arctic and we get into a positive
feedback which would have I believe a
catastrophic impact on the climate now
there's a lot in there that we don't
know we don't know how close we are to
that Tipping Point right it may be that
we're far enough away from it that
nothing that we are currently doing puts
us in danger of Crossing it but nobody
on Earth knows that we're not there what
we have is a mystery where is that
threshold right
so
this is again I'm not telling you that
it's going to happen but I am telling
you I do not believe there's anyone in a
position to say we are safe from it and
absent that we should take it very
seriously right because the we're the
temperature of the earth to rise
suddenly and spectacularly out of our
control because we had released this
pent-up Frozen methane from the Arctic
it would leave us with a much less uh
lovely planet and it would
jeopardize us I believe it's an
existential risk because it would create
uh you know
an instant problem for continuing to
feed all of the people who currently
exist on the earth which means that it
would be destabilizing you'd have
conflict potentially you know up through
nuclear conflict
that would result so again I'm not
telling you this is where we're headed
I'm telling you nobody knows where the
threshold is that dictates whether or
not this thing is
it goes into positive feedback and
becomes run away right which could
happen
tomorrow it could happen it could have
happened three weeks ago and we don't
know it because it would take time for
us to discover it it could be that you
know we could burn fossil fuels for
another 200 years and not cross that we
don't know yeah so anyway I'm not
telling you even that all that is right
but yes my understanding of the puzzle
is that that's the one and that's why
um I am genuinely
uh alarmed about the hazard even if I
don't trust the models that say where we
are and how much warming to expect
excellent I don't have anything to add
it's great
okay the second question from the
Discord this week uh we modified only
slightly
have you ever tried to use your
connections to some of the upper
echelons of money and power to find out
what the something is that you believe
is capture institutions
if so what has been the result
so
I I believe a couple things emerge one
uh if you are not
in a position to have conversations with
very powerful people which is not most
of the conversations we have but they do
happen
with some regularity
[Music]
um
it is surprising how clear it becomes
that they are
in the same position that we find
ourselves with respect to making sense
of the world it is not the case that
Elites are all tapped into some source
of information in which they see stuff
coming and we don't now I'm not saying
no Elites are because I believe that
there are some Elites who are in a very
different position but
um the let's put it this way a
conversation in which we discussed
whether or not
something was taking control of history
and
headed somewhere that conversation would
take place
uh similarly
amongst the people we know irrespective
of where they are in the power hierarchy
nobody knows exactly what's going on and
we talk about it and we speculate about
it and we debate back and forth what the
evidence suggests and
um I guess what I'm telling you is there
are probably people who know folks who
know what's going on but
um
we know some important folks and I don't
think that they are
especially in the know I will also tell
oh go ahead I guess um rereading the
question now I take some issue with the
idea of something
that you believe has capturing
institutions uh there there could be
but it's not going to have been the only
thing that has contributed to
um the downfall so you know just as I
and we have said many times in many
venues
you know the woke in Academia and in
Hollywood and the media and everywhere
right uh is a symptom
of a problem that could not have gotten
in had those institutions been robust
already right and so with regard to
Academia
uh some of some of what happened was the
scientists effectively got siled and and
were eager to Silo themselves because it
came with a release from the duties that
most people prefer not to do and an
increase in Prestige and more money and
resources and all of this but it meant
that the daily functioning the
governance of the University which
should be spread among faculty was
mostly not being done by scientists
it's possible that that was a by Design
sort of thing that is one of the pieces
of the puzzle that I have thought about
a lot ever since you know working in a
Grant's office at a UC University
California school back in the early 90s
um that I have never thought
it worthwhile to spend considerable time
wondering if that piece of it might have
been intentional right
go to the bed I'm sure but that that
piece doesn't seem yeah that piece so
you know something
there's there's not something that
explains all of it no no right
um you know we arrived at some precipice
through a series of you know both
uh errors honest and not and
um people with power and drive that they
shouldn't have had and they had access
they shouldn't have had you know all of
these things and then is it possible
that seeing that coming something
shows up and is you know putting the
screw to it at the very you know what
might be the last minute you know maybe
right but I guess I the concern I have
is the conversation that makes it seem
like there's a thing well so I I think
this Con this of
uh what I typically call Goliath just
for shorthand yeah and the thing about
the Goliath concept is it is a ratio a
ratio that we do not know between
emergent properties and conspiracy we
know that there is conspiracy out there
it could be a very small fraction of the
answer it could be the Lion's Share or
it could be somewhere in between and so
I'm not claiming that the whole thing is
some
single
entity looking to accomplish something
but there's an awful you know we're
going to see a push towards uh
control mechanisms operated through uh
centralized digital Bank currencies and
that's about something right the control
that will be exerted is on behalf of
something and uh so anyway
I guess it's
confusing I guess I I I think I have
been confused by
um
using the term Goliath that represent
amalgam
because the original Goliath as my very
basic understanding from David and
Goliath from the new new testament old
testament okay
um
it's it's a thing that can be fought
oh right right you know and obviously it
doesn't have to be a giant but it's you
know it's a thing that can be fought and
if Goliath is now a stand-in for you
know thing or things that can be fought
plus a whole lot of emergent properties
some of which are you know not even in
existence anymore but they contribute to
the thing like then it's
then you can't even beat David like
David David can't exist if Goliath is an
amalgam that's part of why I use Goliath
as the term is because Goliath ain't a
dude anymore
Goliath is a phenomenon but then David
is not going to be a dude either so
um the point is both of those things
have been scaled up and
um
anyway there's a there's there's a long
road we could go here with respect to
what what we should imagine how how one
fights Goliath all of that
um but the basic point is some fraction
of it again could be small could be
large is steering something we can feel
it right the covid response
was tremendously
coordinated across most of the nations
of the world okay that was something
there was a meeting somewhere right that
decided what it wanted to do
and
um
all what I'm getting at and the answer
to the question
maybe this will make the point
we have gotten contacts from extremely
powerful people who need help
right who were misled
they or people they know vaccine injured
you can't get a doctor who knows what to
do do we know
what they're supposed to do who they're
supposed to talk to that tells me
something yeah right if if the very
powerful people
are in the same boat with respect to
figuring out whether or not to take an
mRNA
so-called vaccine then they're
apparently not in on
whatever it was so
anyway what I would say is
uh the puzzle is more complex than you
think and you probably wouldn't be
comforted
uh that
there's a simple answer to that question
because nobody seems to know that answer
that we are in contact with
yep
question in three parts from
darkhorsesmissions.com
one thank you so much
um
I'm not sure this ends up being a
question one thank you so much my wife
and I agree we couldn't have made it
through the last three years without you
we are so grateful for you to do not
change
uh do we ever get out of this mess
maybe it's actually four questions you
use two twice do not change two again do
we ever get out of this mess my wife has
the best analogy for the last three
years the movie 1408. do you know what I
don't know what okay whenever it looks
like things are getting better the clock
resets and the nightmare starts all over
again
three how are you guys doing really
do we ever get out of this mess I mean
it's related to the last question yeah
it's it's closely related to the last
question and
I guess I'm reminded of
what you say about
going over a waterfall
uh
no matter how close you are to going
over waterfall that if you go over it
will surely kill you
at the moment that you give up hope you
have killed yourself
and so and so you you you must keep
working as hard as you can
to prevent yourself from going over the
waterfall yeah it doesn't so what is the
waterfall here and what is the work that
will be most likely to keep you from
going over the waterfall are the
questions that need answering but you
need you need to keep
you know do we ever get out of this mess
we have to until the answer to that
that's not an answer and it is an answer
we have to until the answer to that
question is definitely no then you put
everything into not going over the
waterfall
um but I would say on a more hopeful
note
um the phenomenon of adaptive valleys is
the Salient one and what that means is
that to get from one opportunity to a
better opportunity
you have to go through one of these uh
very hazardous Transitions and so things
definitely suck
it was pretty well guaranteed that they
were going to we've been so thoroughly
taken care of by the last system which
is now coming apart
that in order for us to make the jump
things had to go awry and so the fact
that things are very far off track
is both terrible there's no guarantee we
get through it but
they were going to have to go off track
for us to switch gears and so this is
that moment in which we either do or we
don't this is the Adaptive Valley
nothing says you definitely get out of
it but
um
but the idea that you were going to do
this without an Adaptive Valley
pretty low likelihood
do you have a charm strategy that you
use in Plate Company with those that
hate your specific facts choice
I'm hoping to have fewer family
gatherings implode but not engagement
hasn't worked
um
you and I do
we do no strategy
yes
what is it
uh we refer to ourselves as dirty and
unvaccinated
and it
puts the people who are quietly thinking
that
in an awkward position because suddenly
they realize who in history they have
become
yeah and and also that they're seen
right outside cat um so anyway I mean I
would suggest something like that right
own it and at the level that you can own
it then
um it will put others at ease that
they're not quietly thinking about this
thing that you you know they know
they're dirty right
yeah so anyway yeah the charm goes a
long way and uh say dirty and
unvaccinated about yourself with a smile
on your face and see if it doesn't
lighten the mood
thank you
yeah
I wish I I wish I had something more but
no that is that is something we've both
done yeah seems to work
we've stopped hemorrhaging friends
that's nice you know
anybody
if the MRNA vacs causes the body to
produce Spike proteins
with the body eventually interpret the
protein as native and stop mitigating it
well that's uh that's what we have to
wonder about the igg4 result that we
talked about last week which I also
talked about with Joe Rogan
um this does look like an attenuation
signal
the real question is if that's what it
is yeah
yeah so yeah
I didn't mean to interrupt you no that
was pretty much what I had to say that's
all you got yeah yeah okay
um
Joe Rogan is a great interviewer who
occasionally steamrolls his guests on a
particular point I feel like we missed a
great opportunity to understand your
difference in opinion on forgiveness
vis-a-vis arguments surrounding vaccine
uptick uptake and reluctance yeah please
re-explain your argument and if you're
able Steel Man his
yeah okay
um
I'll steal man his first Joe's point is
we have all been through some terrible
thing that was of none of our choosing
and that
hate gets you nowhere
and
so we should just Embrace each other and
get over it
Joe I hope that was did you justice my
point to Joe
which is by the way a loser because it's
uglier but your point is a loser yeah my
point to Joe is look I'm
not all that interested in Vengeance I
don't think uh you know if I could press
a button and I could get us to Truth and
Reconciliation where nobody was punished
that would be deeply unjust there are
some people who I believe knowingly did
wrong and should be punished but I would
gladly take that deal in a heartbeat
because I believe the most important
thing to come out of this is a complete
understanding of what happened and
complete understanding of what happened
not only means
how did our Public Health authorities uh
talk us into such dangerous stuff and
continue to push in that direction once
it was obvious that it was a mistake
right that's one level but there's also
another thing which is like
interpersonally for all of us right
think about the person in your life who
this caused the most trouble with right
the friend who just lost and are never
gonna see again whatever what the hell
happened there right you both need to
know what happened there what happened
on their side that they couldn't
understand that you were making sense
what happened on your side you need to
know so my feeling is
um
I'm not even if uh I would be glad to
see bad people punished it doesn't get
me out of bed in the morning at all like
not at all however
at the point that it becomes obvious
that you [ __ ] up you need to stop
doing it and so I do not have any
forgiveness at the moment for people who
are still doubling down on the stuff
that's putting people in danger and
my argument is really simple
if you want to get to the world that we
have to get to
the best way to do it is to leave the
people who are still shooting at us
with an incentive to stop and the
incentive to stop is
stop doing that
own up to what you did
and then we can get past this until then
we're not past it right you're still
shooting and so my feeling is that Joe's
solution while it's definitely
Kinder in its own way results in more
destruction in the end
well and
you're well aware of the distinction but
I feel like you've slightly conflated
uh not being in a forgiving mood with
feeling vengeful
and those are not the same thing
I I agree you you are perhaps the least
vengeful person I've ever met you don't
you don't seem to have it
in you you're not you're not driven by
that
by anger by hatred
um
but that can be true and it is true for
you at the same time as you can say but
I'm not forgiving you you're still
shooting at me
or even I'm not forgiving you uh you
were still shooting at me until
yesterday and now you're pretending it
didn't happen yeah
and then now you're pretending it didn't
happen like I you and I are a little bit
different here but I get really stuck on
that don't
you don't get to pretend that you
weren't doing all of those things that
you were doing no
yep and that's that's also not you know
I have more vengefulness in me than you
do but I don't feel like that's that's a
quest for vengeance either it's a it's a
it's a record that's the word I've been
using is it's a reckoning right that um
actually you're not you're not
trustworthy
if you have been doing all of this for
years now and you stop
and then never another word is said
not trustworthy you'll do it again you
will do it again I I agree it needs to
be a way a reckoning
um uh by the people who have done such
who have behaved this way wherein they
go to their own selves their own Gods
whatever it is
and
achieve some sort of reconciliation
so that the rest of the world however
narrow hour broad that might be for them
can see actually
there is now something in place that
will help prevent that error from
happening again
yeah I agree I think there's a missing
category right there's forgiveness I'm
not gonna forgive somebody if they
haven't even recognized what they did
right but
after forgiveness do I need them
punished not really and I don't actually
think it's all that healthy for us to be
focused on punishing people except for
the very the few Very Bad actors right
the few Very Bad actors are a real
problem at the end of this those people
and people like them need never to be
given power again period that does not
require them to be punished I'd be happy
enough for them to be punished if they
did this knowingly but
um the key thing from the point of view
of our Collective well-being at the end
of this is that the hidden stuff isn't
hidden anymore right this is this is why
what unfolded in South Africa unfolded
that way there was no way to put South
Africa right but there was a way to own
up to what it had been you're talking
about in the 90s yeah
that's where where the phrase truth and
well as far as I know that's where the
phrase Truth and Reconciliation comes
from and the point is that is an
alternative to Ventures right so anyway
Joe and I are
very close together here except that he
does not in my opinion the mistake that
he makes is that he does not leave an
incentive for people to actually face
themselves in the mirror and say I
screwed up and my feelings that That's
essential
yeah I I hate that this is the word we
use in English for this but why would we
facilitate them weaseling
always weaseling out yeah you don't like
that because you like weasels I love
weasels yeah me too yeah weasels aren't
Weasley I agree yeah yeah it's bad [ __ ]
crazy is what that is what are you doing
to the bats all right
so much screaming mm-hmm
asking for a friend I don't know if
that's true or not
um
I am a layperson with a tenured research
PhD as a spouse who refuses to look at
any data that goes against Hiro fauci
and the woke mob what to do and remain
sane
and presumably remain married yeah
that's the key
um you know look I mean you only you
know
your spouse
but you're either gonna
suck it up and find a way to live with
it which is not what I would recommend
because I do think it'll eat at you
forever
or you're gonna have a look honey
conversation right and that's the only
person who knows how to have that
conversation with your particular spouse
is you if that
um but you know better than anybody else
does and the point is look I can't live
with this right you are in the sway of
something terrifying and it is
understandable how you found yourself
there because it was very persuasive and
very hard for many people to find their
way out but
you know it's not 2021 anymore
there's an awful lot of evidence and
they're an awful lot of sane people who
have shown the way out and to the extent
that you're blinding yourself
right that's kind of on you at this
point well and it's and the woke mob so
you know I take this to be you know in
sway to the woke and to the medically
woke yeah to use your framing uh and
I have met a number of people
who have
wrestled with this a little bit within
relationships
um these weren't relationships though in
which their spouse was uh completely on
the other side which is which from you
know a two-line sentence two-line
question it's hard to know you know
there's obviously not much detail here
um but and it's not just been actually
most of the people I'm thinking of are
women whose husbands weren't seeing
things
um that they were seeing and have sort
of slowly woken their husbands up and
you know I and I have said the first few
times I I talked to people in the
situation I was like I'm I'm surprised
you know you usually it will be
um that the the women have been in this
way of woke and medically woke and that
the men have been able to see it because
they are less agreeable that's you know
one level of answer to the question on
average
less agreeable on average
um but it happens in both directions
presumably within homosexual couples as
well and
because because there aren't even
generalities like
well given that you're probably a guy
who's trying to convince his wife
because actually more of the stories
that I've heard of the other way around
it's really hard to give any kind of
particulars here um
except I guess find
find the pieces you know a tenured
research PhD
but there's probably going to be more
amenable to reading a short piece that's
not snarky and that appears to have
evidence
uh than watching a YouTube video
right uh so you know find find those
pieces and share them and don't over
burden the person and uh you know some
of
some of what not all of them by any
means but some of the pieces that I
write
on Natural Selections are specifically
designed with that in mind to be to be
something that can be shared with people
who don't see it this way at all yeah
yeah
um
your sub stack is good for this
do me Kim I think I think also somebody
who uh
is particularly clear I think she does a
better job so I don't I think what I end
up talking about covet on my sub stack
uh I have not really tried and I'm not
sure that I would yet be good at
um
being sufficiently removed to those
pieces mostly are not gonna
fly well with people who aren't already
questioning a little bit of it I'm
thinking more of the pieces over and
sort of sex and gender territory my I am
a woman piece and what the girls do
those are both pieces that I have
suggested that people share with
actually their adult children you know I
know I know some women who have adult
children who think they're crazy to not
think that anyone who calls himself a
woman is a woman and I said you've got
these two pieces that they've
specifically were designed to you know
to be shared by people who you know just
are you know can read really uh so I
think Jamie does a very good job um I
can't think of any individual pieces of
hers but um and and I'll look up what
her sub stack is called
um
you were going to say some others well I
mean I'm clearly caught up over in
coveted space and so maybe I'm just
punting on the fact that this is no go
for it all right so hers is called let's
be clear
and it's Jimmy
johni.substack.com yeah I think I think
I've offered what I can offer I don't
think okay
I'm in a particularly good spot to say
more
um do you have a reference
on uh Happy hypoxics some cause of
hypoxia are silent with unawareness like
carbon monoxide poisoning other causes
have awareness such as alveolar sex
along with fluid causing difficulty
breathing and respiratory distress
so that's an interesting case because in
the case of carbon monoxide we can say
why the effect is there yeah and in fact
it does mirror what we described uh here
with respect to that mechanism of action
oh but like why at The evolutionary
level not at the mechanism mechanism of
action level from monoxide
if I know what you're going to say so I
would point to two parts of it the thing
about carbon monoxide
is it has an affinity for hemoglobin
higher than oxygen and so what it tends
to do is bind hemoglobin and not let it
go which means that the hemoglobin is
therefore not available for transporting
oxygen out of the lungs which means that
if you're measuring a proxy like how
well am I breathing you're breathing
fine right which is why it doesn't cause
disturbance
now carbon dioxide
does cause disturbance
hemoglobin is actually kind of a
remarkable molecule because of the way
it can capture
carbon dioxide and then release it in
the lungs and exchange it for oxygen
right the ability to trade these
molecules out at the right moment is
pretty freaking cool frankly
um but the key difference the reason
that uh carbon dioxide does not have the
same
effect and that it does cause distress
is that we have a detector
for elevated carbon dioxide and the
reason that we have a detector for
elevated carbon dioxide is that because
fires and creatures breathing and all of
that put out carbon dioxide naturally at
high levels
person is even a hazard to themself if
you go into a cave that's tight enough
you can fill it up with carbon dioxide
and so we have a panic response that's
built in before the Industrial
Revolution the world was full of carbon
dioxide yep and so we have a long
selective history of needing to be aware
of it right whereas carbon monoxide not
so much right and you know somebody a
nitpicker could say well there's carbon
monoxide put out of you know in the
smoke of a fire right but fire is also
putting out carbon dioxide at a high
rate and so the point is the one
detector probably covers you and it
takes industrialization before carbon
monoxide carbon monoxide becomes a
serious Hazard so anyway the um the idea
that if you're breathing well right
mechanically
and
um you're just not exchanging gases
properly that unless the gas is one that
you're built to detect uh rising and for
it to make you uncomfortable that you
may be comfortable too comfortable the
question I never understood about the
happy hypoxics
was
that they seem physically less
compromised than doctors expected them
to be right a doctor would look at
they're not just delusional with regard
to mood they're actually moving around
yeah so I don't remember much about this
Steve you don't know I don't have a
reference on the top of my head but my
guess is if you were to Google or better
Google Scholar happy hypoxic you'd find
it hmm
okay
um
can you address the study that John
Campbell that Dr John Campbell removed
from his YouTube
I don't know I do let me try to remember
it I briefly saw this he removed
uh
uh could you Google it I just need a
trigger I can't remember exactly what it
was John Campbell removed a study from
his YouTube
Channel this week
um
two months ago
you might look on Twitter
[Music]
uh
is the date right I don't I don't know
I'm no it's not so there's a bunch of a
bunch of John Campbell removes things so
I don't I don't know what I'm looking
for yeah and unfortunately I don't
remember it happened and it didn't
directly capture my there's just a lot
of these and they're all from like mid
2022 news
two years ago
I believe I think this is I'm seeing
YouTube
with the correct date with recent 18
hours ago okay what was it yesterday
and remove this video
the risk of coca-19 also varied whether
it's a little bit hard to say
well I I I I don't know enough yeah
maybe we'll return to it but I I can't
do anything if I can't get the topic
back
uh do you know how the medical
anthropology field is going is anything
awesome happening or has it been
captured unbrainwashed research possible
or not and then there's a follow-up uh
regarding medical anthropology I want to
I meant especially regarding topics of
the last few years
I don't know
uh I don't see really any evidence that
any of the subfields of anthropology are
pulling their heads out of the sand and
that's being nice
uh good use of sand
sand Ah that's not where they're pulling
their heads out from under failing to
but
I didn't look too closely no
um it's probably for the best
uh
yeah I
anthropology unfortunately uh as one of
the core social science disciplines is
really deeply confused and frankly so I
have my bachelors my bachelor's degrees
in anthropology from the early 90s and
it was already pretty deeply confused
then
uh there was a lot of ideological stuff
um passing as science
and I see no evidence that it's gotten
any better anywhere and that include I
did I did do some medical anthropology
uh back then and uh was
acting you know it's anecdotal because
it was one researcher in the medical
anthropology who was teaching this class
but she actively directed me away from
the questions that I was interested in
and the conclusions that I was Finding
in the research
and I actually ran across something when
I was when I ended up finding this
fourth grade
this this week sorry
um I ran across some of some of the
college work and you know I didn't
misremember that yeah she that's that
that happened just don't worry about it
yeah
um yeah it's hard to imagine of all
fields that medical anthropology could
be shining at this moment right it's got
all of the pressures on it and uh I also
think we would have heard from them if
they somehow had resisted then uh we
that would be famous so anyway I would
bet strongly against yeah
okay I forgot to look when we started
Zach
okay uh how can
how come this is a big one how can we
avoid or at least regularly detox
ourselves of the many endocrine
disruptors in our water air food Etc
yeah I don't think you I don't think you
can I think you can reduce your intake
avoid and regular and detox are
different yeah right like I don't I
don't think
I don't think there's anywhere on the
planet at this point that you can avoid
all of it yep uh and you can certainly
live farther and farther and farther
from the urban centers and downstream of
industrial plants and feedlots and etc
etc but it's it's it's everywhere we've
what we have done is spreading and has
spread everywhere on this beautiful
planet of ours
um
and then detoxing for endocrine
disruptors you know I don't I've never
thought about specifically those you
know detox for endocrine disruptors as
opposed to
just you know generally trying to do you
know purges or cleanses or something but
um certainly things like fasting and
sauna
are useful for for some such things but
especially you know
lipophilic molecules are gonna
hide in your fat and and
you know you'll know you've gotten some
of it if you do do something like a fast
or Purge and you feel really bad
for a little while but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that was healthy
for you or that you got the right stuff
or you know any of it so it's
hard I don't know
avoid as much as you can uh because it's
dose dependent avoidance
is good even though it's not complete
thoughts on AI as a tool to make art I
seem to be among the minority of authors
and artists who are for it
um I think it's actually pretty useful
for destroying art I can't see how
it's going to be useful for making art I
think it could be useful for making
stuff that you can sell as if it were
art
um that said
a limited kind of AI could be utilized
by an artist but I think the problem
with it is as we are learning with uh
chat GPT the capacity to know very
little and get it to do
work positive or negative uh is too
great
um so anyway I'm uh art is the least of
our concerns I would say even though it
is not a small one
um but that we are we are somewhere new
with uh emerging Ai and uh
I think you're right to be concerned
well no
this person is embedded in a group of
people who think it's positive but I
think
you dear viewer would be right to be
concerned
um
that was a weird sort of an answer for
you
um not not the conclusion but
um
I think what it will come down to for me
and I suspect many of the people who
feel as Brett does and like I think
majority of people
uh feel that uh it AI doesn't have any
place in art is unfortunately going to
sound uh pedantic and semantic which is
to say what is art like you
if
if you feel if if upon trying to figure
out what your definition of art is you
come to the conclusion that it is
inherently a human activity
uh I guess there could be an argument
that AI is a human creation and
therefore this is just an indirect you
know it's it's just two steps later
um but that feels to me pretty semantic
and pedantic as well uh
I similarly
I I think that art is human
and uh I can't remember was it Coco the
gorilla or some elephant or you know
there have been these or maybe even
crows who might even understand what
they're doing but I feel like there's
been various forms of art there's
definitely elephant art 2D stuff that
gets presented as like look art like
well
maybe that could be that could be
interesting to reveal something about
the mind of the elephant but I don't I I
don't call it art
because to for me the definition
involves human human as the foundation
uh whereas you know science isn't
inherently human
right like science could be done by
by you could teach an AI to hypothesis
test yeah
um but I think art is I I agree and the
reason is because
uh of meaning and my concern about AI
art is that it will be able
art is two-way street
you've got somebody creating something
and then you have somebody interpreting
something and the problem is if you can
get us something to create something
that your mind will interpret as if it
was Art but it's not a somebody
then
you're going to impose meaning on it
even if there is none
right so my feeling is that's dangerous
right art isn't immune because the thing
will spit out something that seems an
awful lot like art right it'll be able
to make a movie that you're gonna love
right but the problem is that you will
love it
and you're going to therefore just as
you look for meaning in the lyrics of a
song yeah right you're going to look for
meaning where there isn't any and it is
going to drive us insane
I wonder if there's Not So this
this is a different point than the human
point but I wonder if it's not similar
to the objection to synthetic boy bands
yep right absolutely so you've got four
guys who have some native Talent
but they definitely have to look pretty
and someone has an idea and someone has
money and someone and like it's it's the
it's the production level that creates
the band that
produces the music and I'd like I I
can't even do it without putting up the
scare quotes right like is is that
is it music I guess you know it's being
created by the humans but like this like
yeah no it's music but the point is it
is deceptive right it's not the boys in
the boy band that make the music it's
some middle-aged guy who writes the song
and then you know some group of people
trains the maybe barely talented or
maybe slightly talented boys in the boy
band to pretend that it's them and so it
deceives it's phony but it's not not
music hey dude leave my water alone
um
um so there's that
but
I mean music is the right way to do this
it's algorithmic enough
that if you train an AI to figure out
what is irresistible musically it's
gonna figure it out right it's not there
yet but actually we've been headed there
with with respect to music for quite
some time and just like laugh track gets
people to think things are funny that
aren't funny right it's very dangerous
when you start tapping that directly
into this stuff the meaning of which we
do not understand yeah what are the
chances you're going to be deeply
surprised
by something that the AI comes up with
well somebody will program it to deeply
surprise you but the point is you it's
not a meaningful it's not an artist who
has the same experience that you do in
listening to a piece deciding to
introduce something to cause you to you
know have that experience so uh my
feeling is
um this is a classic case you are not
going to be able to spell out exactly
how this is going to wreck cognition but
it is
and the fact that you can't spell it out
ahead of time is going to mean there's
no way we can have a proper conversation
about how dangerous this is and how
important it is that we not allow it
that's right and what does not allow it
even mean right right you know you're
not going to let a kid program a
Raspberry Pi to make something musically
sounding musical sounding no you can't
so anyway I wish they hadn't let whoever
programmed our microwave make something
musical sounding holy moly is our
microwave tone deaf
it really is yeah yeah it's too chipper
also it's so happy
all right we have not faced this but
imagine that you uh are heating up your
coffee
uh at a funeral
like microwave I think Chimes you don't
microwave your coffee at a funeral Brett
I think that was your first time plus
you've just gotten home from a funeral
but then you're not there anymore but
you're still microwaving in the context
you're still grieving yes your microwave
would at least need to just pass up the
stage you're still grieving
definitely okay and then you our
microwave sure oh it's oh this greeting
persons come over to our house
I was imagining that it was one of us
which I I'm not hoping for this I'm just
saying
it's just got weird facing our microwave
in a grieving mindset I say I cannot see
how you would not end up
you know grabbing a meat tenderizing
Mallet and tenderizing the microwave
sure sure for a lot of shippers but also
like oh my God just came back from the
funeral it's I know what I need hot
coffee
yeah that that'll improve my day
yeah yeah no just
old but hot coffee
all right
um I feel like the Prototype AI trying
to provide meaning and you're just gonna
get better and that's the problem that's
the problem next time with the scenario
you'll see yeah I know and well at some
soon long Zach and I'll be humming along
like yeah
that does sound right yeah we will have
brought the microwave as a funeral gift
or something and
foreign
for the dead or for the living who do
you who do you give as a gift to
there are plenty of cultures in which
the dead have been left with things to
take with them to that his life
unfortunately good point you're right
and they didn't need those things either
so I put the dead back on recipients
but lots of valuable stuff I mean you
know grave robbing is a thing for a
reason right yeah
oh yeah maybe they're just sleeping yeah
yeah all right this has now again gotten
weird okay
hmm
do I don't do any animals spawn
non-gamate cells that survive externally
I don't know what that means I know what
it means oh
um yeah
is there asexual reproduction by budding
yeah there is
um you can certainly divide a starfish
uh and and some corals I think
maybe yeah well yeah but let's say five
externally yep well no spot so the spawn
suggests
uh separation so rather than
but yeah I mean starfish may be the
obvious
vertebrates is going to be a no
I think arthropods is going to be a no
yeah yeah kind of derms and maybe some
something Beyond starfish which you're
Economist uh which are actually super
closely related to vertebrates
um
[Music]
where you can but I don't that's not
spawning though so similarly some of the
word and worm is a terrible group
they're billion not a billion a lot of
types of worms but some of them like
earthworms you can like you can cut and
then both halves can go on to be to be
okay nothing does something like apple
mixes
so that's what I'm trying to come up
with
no I'm just gonna be something well
animals animals
spawn
non-gamied cell so externally
and spawn I understand to be
it removes itself as opposed to if a
force comes in and cuts it off can the
smaller piece survive so all the
parthenogenetic stuff
fertilizes
Gekko I don't know all the Squire mates
yes
all the them they're in these things so
all the lizards
um
but there's a lot there's a lot of part
there's a lot of parthenogenesis and
parts of the animal tree that I'm not as
familiar with yeah yeah I mean oh and I
only
yeah but no fish that I I really don't
think it's gonna happen in vertebrates
if it happens
yeah I can talk about chronotarsal
ankles though if you'd like well what we
are discussing is the possibility that
something goes through a phase in which
it produces something egg-like
uh
mitotically rather than meiotically
and that's awfully hard to rule out but
probably it's been looked at and
everything we know reproduces
genetically it's probably been either
ruled out or seen
yep
anyway yeah I wish I knew the answer to
this question I don't off the top of my
head yeah
oh
for lineages with little economic power
would lineage preference be more
beneficial
uh than outside cooperation
buying from it feels like this got cut
off
uh okay I'm gonna read it again for
lineages with little economic power
would lineage preference be more
beneficial than outside cooperation
question mark parentheses buying from or
doing business with
um think actually you might have It
reversed
because if you've got a lineage with
little economic power and economic power
should stand in for capacity to adjust
its circumstances
the
the big win comes if you can jump
in terms of power to affect the position
of your lineage in other words
if you marry up for example into a
lineage that has well but so sex
specific stuff is going to be different
right but I'm not sure it's not the
right model to be using here right I
mean for one thing you could just do the
same thing economically let's say it's
not sex but you know you uh are a farmer
you know in a subsistence capacity and
you get an opportunity to uh
join a company you know in a different
economic strata then the point is you're
actually in a position to take some or
all of your prior lineage and change
where they are and well I'm trying
I wish I was coming up with more
examples but I'm thinking of sort of
famously insular communities like
Orthodox Jews and Romani gypsies
uh and you know gypsies have looked a
lot of different ways a lot of different
places as do Orthodox Jews a little less
a little less variation but I believe in
both cases certainly with regard to
Orthodox Jews
while the social and familial stuff is
definitely kept within tribe if you will
there is explicitly Commerce outside
and I believe that's the case with
Romani as well very different in terms
of um
itinerant
moving and offering sort of
offering services that may not be
available otherwise you know theater
Etc
um but it that seems to demonstrate
those seem to be examples of what you're
talking about yeah I think
yeah
okay
would vaccine-driven immune Escape
variants
affect the unvaxxed and the vaxed
similarly
uh no they might affect both the vexed
and the unvaxxed but to the extent that
they are Escape ease
uh uh of the vaccination program
they're variance driven by the so-called
vaccines
then they will tend to create
[Music]
um
vulnerability for those who have that
narrow immunity
so they don't so the answer is nobody
escapes vulnerability but the
vulnerability will be different
I'm it's not clear to me why
if it's brand new even if it's brand new
because of selective pressure from the
narrow rendering of the vaccines yeah
that if you have one of those narrowly
rendered vaccines on board you or if you
don't if you are now exposed to
something that is different
uh from what the vaccine was perhaps in
a position to respond to initially why
would your immune system inherently you
know it's novel to you either way
um
right
I think the answer is a trade-off answer
which is
the virus has whatever confirmation it
has in advance of the selective pressure
exerted by the so-called vaccines
that's a better structure than it is
driven to by the vaccines it is driven
to do something specifically to escape a
particular narrow kind of immunity and
therefore it is giving up the more ideal
structure it is likely to have had
previously and it's likely to go ahead
well but so that I think if I if I
understood you correctly or maybe I just
jumped in my own head I think the
comparison where the answer to this
would would almost certainly be yes
would be vaxxed versus has natural
vaxxed and otherwise unexposed to covid
and unfaxed and has natural immunity
from having been exposed to covet that's
certain so then you've got a broader
immunity versus a narrow immunity and
that narrow immunity specifically is is
no way a match for the thing that has
evolved because of the narrow narrowly
targeted vaccines but just vax versus
unvaxed seems like it's like if facts
versus unfaxed but they're but
everyone's been exposed to covid
I don't know why the status of just
being vaccinated should make you should
should render your immune response
different necessarily well I mean we're
not going to rehash all this stuff about
original antigenic Sentinel but I do
think that that's where it goes you're
creating a known Target and what's more
you're creating an awful lot of copies
of it yeah so you're you're creating an
environment in which Evolution will
solve that puzzle and find you
rather than them yeah but you know but
but if you've also been exposed to coven
and therefore you have broadened me I
mean unless well there's also a question
that were exposed before or after yep
yep um yeah so it's yeah there's a many
many categories actually that weren't
comparison yep
let's do two more
I don't know what this is referring to
New Zealand and California recently
decriminalized certain forms of
pedophilia one by Court one by Statute
is this a maladaptation of the left's
concern with pushing rigid boundaries
I don't know if it's enemy action the
natural consequence of a
trajectory that has just deranged us
but assuming the setup to your question
is right
it's obviously
civilization revealing that it has
completely lost the plot and forgotten
what it is supposed to do
um
and you know I I think some of it also
is not really just the left and its
particular beliefs about uh tolerance
that have obviously been misapplied here
but I also think this has to do with
porn and the idea just like with
[Music]
um
Ophthalmology and the false story that
bad genes would explain why people
differ in their quality of their
eyesight just as it is with orthodontia
and the belief that bad genes are the
reason that people have their teeth end
up in the wrong relationship to each
other
there's a sense of like you know
well whatever your Kink is is your Kink
right that you didn't choose that yeah
the answer is well maybe you didn't
choose it but you may have decided to
allow it to be reinforced
right or maybe you chose to
Source some porn and Amplified it and
the point is no these things are not all
inherently valid just because you feel
them and so anyway I feel like well if
it's true that you know I don't know
what people's Kink is right but
you know
whatever it is that people are getting
off on if that's valid then well why not
this other thing and then you have to
make some complex argument about actual
harm and well what if you just like it
and you don't do actual harm and you
know it's nonsense so
I feel like it's it's that it's there's
some rudimentary
oversimplification in which people just
decide that uh because they want to be
tolerant that
um you know that all sexual desires are
valid
yeah it feels maybe like an overlay of
libertarian instincts with postmodern
instincts
um and then confusion ensues with regard
to those who maybe don't even have those
instincts but are told well you have to
because uh I'm you know the assumption
that is ever less said is well I'm not
hurting anyone right like that in order
to actually be libertarian there will be
Libertarians they'll get mad here I'm
like well it can't you know there can't
be externalities
well increasingly the externalities that
actually exist are denied and the ones
uh that don't exist are claimed and so
you got a confusion all around about
like what the actual costs are and uh
the postmodern bit is well my feelings
Trump your reality so
um
I get you know the the desires of the
few uh are more important than the
actual health and safety of the majority
somehow that's that's where we are
that's what we got to yeah but I I do
feel like this is in addition to
everything else one could say about the
topic it also constitutes a perfectly
valid test for who retains a mind
all right at the point your civilization
starts playing with that boundary
right you should automatically think
okay what the hell happened here yep
right what has gone wrong right you
should not well maybe they're right nope
they aren't right right what has gone
wrong is the only question
yep
and so we got all this tone policing
don't call them groomers
uh actually there were a bunch more
questions that I hadn't seen yet so
we're gonna do two more here
and we'll still miss a bunch of them
what do you make of the study that found
high levels of Spike proteins Unbound by
antibodies in the blood of vaccinated
individuals
versus those without I've learned much
from you and I'm deeply grateful could
you repeat it I think I got it but I I
don't know the study so if neither of us
do we can't respond to it
what do you make of the study that found
high levels of Spike proteins Unbound by
antibodies in the blood of vaccinated
individuals with myocarditis versus
those without
heard this mentioned but I haven't
looked at it myself yeah
um I guess I would say on the one hand
there's a temptation
I think people have recognized that
spike is
dangerous
and therefore likely to be associated
with all the pathologies and I
increasingly see a dichotomy between
pathologies that are indeed Spike
related which will for example be
produced by both of the versions of the
so-called vaccines
and pathologies that are not Spike
related that are the result of the
destruction of One's Own cells that uh
will happen at the at the hand of T
cells when the mrnas cause them to
transcribe
or translate Spike protein so it's not
the spike protein doing the harm it's
the advertising of foreign protein and
it would work no matter which foreign
protein it was
so myocarditis
is going to be largely if not entirely
the result of
cells in the heart transcribing the
mrnas and then being targeted by immune
cells that's not
Downstream of Spike right it's caused
its spike is almost incidental in that
story it is displayed on the surface of
those cells those cells get targeted as
if they're virally infected and that
causes the hazard so anyway they're just
the signal
right
um so that doesn't mean you wouldn't
expect exactly that result but it means
that you shouldn't causally connect
free-floating Spike with the myocarditis
because I don't think that's what's
going on
uh one more comment and then last
question uh comment listen again to
Brett's conversation with Jonathan pagio
in light of David and Goliath talk I
really want to hear you talk to Matthew
pajo
do you have thoughts on the goings-on
with Dr Jordan Peterson in this fine New
Year thank you for being have a smiley
day many greetings from Norway
foreign
they are
I want to I wanted to say I was gonna
say they are playing with fire I really
hope they've discovered that they are
playing with fire
uh may he may he Triumph oh he's going
to Triumph I cannot imagine so how are
you so confident
um if Triumph includes him keeping his
uh his his license yeah I don't know
that he will keep his license but I do
think a
they obviously wouldn't have done this
if they were going to back down easily
they must have assumed they were going
to Triumph in the end rather than back
down which means that they're dummies
because this is not a fight they should
have picked
um
so anyway my sense is you know look if I
found out
maybe they thought maybe they wanted to
do it all along and they waited until he
they were like maybe maybe maybe they
actually thought he'd roll over
um so anyway my sense is he's gonna
Triumph because it's very clear what
he's going to do and who are these
people again it's the Canadian Board of
such and such as I mean who are these
people right they're
they're not Jordan Peterson they're not
Jordan Peterson so anyway
um I feel terrible for Jordan that he's
facing this on the other hand
um he got where he is
knowing exactly how to address
situations like this one and if they
destroy
Canadian psychology because they have to
throw Jordan out for
being employed in tweets or whatever it
is that they're he um criticized Trudeau
and I believe he retweeted Pierre uh
forgot how to pronounce his last name
the
um Olivier the the conservative guy who
was running for prime minister
um which
obviously A Bridge Too Far yeah I mean
criticizing Trudeau that guy how could
he how could anyone criticize Trudeau
he's almost Beyond yeah so anyway I
expect Jordan to Triumph by one route or
the other and
you can't take them seriously they
obviously don't understand who they are
who he is what psychology is so anyway
it's one more field advertising that it
doesn't have a clue
yeah
true there are a lot of people who need
who rely on clinical psychologists to
figure themselves out or to get
themselves back on track
and
yeah Academia successfully
got rid of a lot of people
and if psychology
which you know
I'm sure is filled with a bunch of lauts
and buffoons like every field is but if
it's going to uh and you know I don't I
have no idea if Jordan has been acting
as a clinician at all you know in the
last several times right but and I mean
I've said this to you before I think I
think that he and we actually came to
some of our insights about people uh yes
he was a professor as well but I think
us in the particular kinds of classrooms
that we had because of the particular
institution we were at on him through
his clinical practice
really cared deeply about the people in
our cases the small numbers of students
in his cases his relatively small number
of patients whom he got to know and
could see how they responded to being
told the truth and being you know being
treated with respect and honor and being
told the truth even when it hurt right
and so even if he really hasn't been
acting as a clinician for a while and
really didn't have any active plans to
go back to it
the prospect of being told actually not
for you anymore is is a large one that's
that's a big loss even if it's entirely
theoretical well
I'm not arguing it's not a loss but I'm
arguing
you have an invalid field
ing
um
and
I mean look
it's bad but it's no different than
suddenly all of us who need to have
doctors that we can go to have an entire
field of people who turn out to be
fakers
right yeah it's that so the point is
look
it's probably true that in order to find
a psychologist worth their salt you are
going to have to step out of the
officialdum and then you're gonna have
to figure out
how it gets paid for because maybe it's
not going to be insurance I know of two
right but
so that's that's the answer and look I'm
not saying that that's an acceptable
system that's not why I'm comfortable
with it why would this be
any different than any of these other
things right we lost all of medicine
they're all gone right you've got like a
small handful of people who
figured their way through the puzzle and
then you've got a lot of other people
with a degree and a job who staff
hospitals and do whatever else who turn
out not to be
capable of
seeing a corporate fiction
passed along as if it were science
right so anyway it's you know okay
psychology too not surprised
yeah
well on that hopeful note
we'll see you in the second week of the
new year when we expect everything will
have turned around yes and our lighting
will be back
well you know it's a work of progress
yes yes this is this is Moody
um so moody so moody yeah all right uh
we'll be back next week on what I guess
will be the 14th of January uh until
then we encourage you to be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside
be well
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]